on passe tout de suite à notre second
débat et comme c'est notre dernière
émission dans les fêtes de noël on a
décidé de s'offrir un petit plaisir en
parlant de l'humour et des vacheries en
politique une campagne électorale
évidemment c'est un concentré de pics de
bons mots et parfois malheureusement
d'agressivité marion delpech
la campagne présidentielle est lancée et
avec elle son lot de petites phrases
assassines
cette semaine par exemple la nouvelle
championne de la droite était dans le
collimateur des macros nice tu es là la
fébrilité comme moteur et l'hypocrisie
comme carburant parce que la réalité
c'est qu'elle dit aujourd'hui l' inverse
de ce qu elle disait à l'époque la
candidate des républicains n'est pas en
reste en octobre dernier elle
s'attaquait déjà emmanuel macron lors
d'une conférence de presse je crois que
le président macron a été inspiré par
machiavel vous le savez vous connaissez
cette fameuse phrase de machiavel
machiavel disait gouverner c'est faire
croire plus récemment elle s'en prenait
à la candidate du rassemblement national
qu'est ce que vous dites à marine le pen
qui évoquent eux leucate karl bretons en
parlant de l'affairé l'air et qui dit
que finalement la droite est extrêmement
fracturé aujourd'hui mais comme marine
le pen est bretonne j'imagine qu'elle
aime le 4/4 et elle va en bouffer
beaucoup de son côté marine le pen se
fait-elle plus discrète et feint
d'ignorer les nombreuses attaques d'eric
zemmour pour marine le pen je la plains
de devoir reprendre de parler comme
marlène schiappa de parler comme la
gauche de parler comme les féministes je
la plains de devoir reprendre des
arguments mais vous savez j'avais été le
premier à le dire il ya le diagnostic et
c'est une femme de gauche et les piques
se multiplient envers les adversaires du
candidat
moi je dis oui emmanuel macron c'est le
vide et c'est d'un adolescent qui n'est
pas fini une brutalité qui raymond
revendique et assume en meetings et sur
les plateaux de télévision du côté de
l'elysée on fait la sourde oreille
emmanuel macron a préféré hier les
attaques en creux contre valérie
pécresse ou encore eric zemmour c'est
plutôt le porte parole du gouvernement
qui s'adonnent aux joutes verbales quand
nous avons dû
il nous a vendus qu'il était le trump
français c'est un train peut commander
sur we show comme on dit c'est plate
forme de contrefaçon la qui vend des
trucs qui fonctionne pas qu'ils sont
faux à gauche jean luc mélenchon s'en
est pris à la candidate des républicains
avec ses talents d'orateur elle a dit
dale même qu'elle était un terme cher de
terre merkel ce qui ne laisse pas grand
chose de bon
il n'a pas non plus ménagé anne hidalgo
et son idée de primaires de la gauche
avec ce genre de comédies ont fini bord
du goût de tout le monde et cette année
la culture du clash en politique servi
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux le
candidat de la france un soumises s'est
mis au rap pour critiquer ses
adversaires
injures humour et politique attention ça
pique voilà le thème de notre débat et
j'accueille l enppi chomsky bonsoir
bienvenue journaliste éditorialiste jean
garrigues historiens toujours là merci
d'être resté son poulet et vous êtes
toujours présent du comité histoire
parlementaire vous avez publié elysées
circus une histoire drôle et cruelle des
présidentielles c'est chez tallandier
bruno fuligni essayiste bonsoir bruno
heureux de vous retrouver vous publiez
le petit dictionnaire des injures
politique c'est aux éditions du rocher
laetitia khl pas est toujours à mes
côtés bruno c'est c'est cette réédition
c'est une réédition de du livre qui qui
nous a donné envie d'organiser ce débat
donc merci parce que ça nous permet
d'avoir un débat dans lequel on va on va
se balader dans les époques et dans
l'est et dans l'épique multiples et
variées j'aurais quand même que vous
puissiez les uns et les autres pour
commencer réagir un peu à ça assure
portage et cette campagne présidentielle
agressif parfois violentes est-ce que
c'est forcément nouveau pas complètement
d'abord si on est dans une perspective
un peu longue les injures politique
d'aujourd'hui sont plutôt douce par
rapport à ce qu'ils pouvaient s'échanger
autant de la sphère dreyfus ou bien dans
des années 30 où on allait facilement à
l'appel au meurtre on on allait très
très très loin dans l'abjection là
aujourd'hui on a plutôt des petites
piques d'humoriste
sous la vème république
c'est un peu une tradition joly c'est un
petit peu mais mes fiches
on a en 1974 à l'extrême gauche arlette
laguiller qui se présente comme
candidate c'est un petit peu nouveau une
femme qui se présente comme candidate
d'extrême gauche en plus une saillie de
du général bigeard il faut la mariée à
un parachutiste bon vous voyez ça
passerait plus vraiment aujourd'hui et
on pourrait multiplier ce type ce type
d' attaque on a dit on a traité françois
mitterrand de tout on a traité georges
marchais de tout e même n'était pas en
reste donc il ya toujours eu du france
dans toutes nos campagnes
présidentielles des attaques après il
faut voir le niveau la première vraie
campagne présidentielle moderne au
suffrage universel c'est celle de 65 un
an avant françois mitterrand sort le
coup d'état permanent on peut en
détacher toutes sortes de phrases qui
sont vraiment des attaques de type enflé
terre contre de gaulle mais c'est bien
écrit c'est bien ajustée sans aucune
grossièreté c'est un livre au christ est
un pamphlet mais c'est un bon relais
mais c'est un pamphlet
verra-t-on toujours un français coiffé
la couronne de patagonie voici une façon
assez génial et assez élégante de à
partir d'une référence historique de de
tourner en ridicule celui qui est le
chef de l'état ni le compas aussi un
dictateur mais en mettant les gants bon
et puis après on a des attaques beaucoup
plus
superficiels ou beaucoup plus grossières
qui n'ont pas le même intérêt bien sûr
une petite chose qui cette
présidentielle vous la trouvez on va pas
remonter aussi loin mais si on la
compare aux deux précédentes
élection de françois hollande ou de
nicolas sarkozy est ce que vous la
trouvez plus agressive ou plus violente
que les précédentes finalement non dans
l'agressivité il y en a toujours eu elle
s'exprime différemment à mon sens c'est
à dire elle c'est ce que je disais à
l'instant là elle s'est terriblement
concentrés autour de la personne
d'emmanuel macron marqué du temps de
nicolas sarkozy mais du tour de nicolas
sarkozy tout du moins quand il a été élu
pour la deuxième pour sa deuxième
candidature c'était plus compliqué là il
était vraiment dans la cible de lui
aussi mais quand il a été élu bomba
sarkozy dominer c'était une évidence que
maintenant il ya une bagarre pour le
titre de président je mérite je mérite
pas et surtout cette concentration sur
emmanuel macron moi ça me révolte parce
que finalement ça appauvrit la colle la
campagne présidentielle en ce sens que
tout a été focalisé sur comment faire
pour le dégager comment faire pour le
dégager on lui laisse à peine le temps
de s'exprimer vous êtres dont moi je
trouve que c'est assez assez étonnant il
n'y a pas beaucoup de thèmes de bataille
est ce que vous pourriez vous dire il ya
le thème il ya l'immigration en tout le
monde a compris l'immigration
effectivement ça c'est le thème
dominateur ça c'est clair elle a été en
tout cas est-ce que ça l'est parce qu'il
est quelqu'un qui est arrivé et on a
campagne parce qu'il ya eu de démarrer
très tôt c'est une éruption lloris et
mots et puis ensuite la primaire la
primaire ait l'air donc ça a été
effectivement à un thème fort mais il ya
un élément que vous citez pas au moins
je voudrais citer c'est quand même là la
montée en puissance des réseaux sociaux
de abba 8 heures jean garrigues le fait
aussi que les candidats maintenant son
film est quasiment en permanence on dit
ça change aussi la capacité d'un homme
ou d'une femme politique à un peu se
lâcher
non j'ai pas fini je voulais dire qu'on
triptyque il ya des réseaux sociaux les
chaînes les chaînes d'info en cours 3e
troisième pied du traité les sondages et
si vous si vous concentrer tout ça il ya
plus rien d'autre à côté tout est là
dedans
alors d'abord sur la concentration sur
une manuelle accro elle est un peu
traditionnelle président sortant
concentre toujours les positions autour
de lui et y compris ce type de
d'insultant fin de de dénigrement mais
vous allez va voir aussi une lutte
farouche à droite pour la candidature ou
au second tour et certainement que les
noms d'oiseaux en tout cas les petites
père phil irons selah sue êtes abonnés
entre valérie pécresse et eric zemmour
et ça commence d'ailleurs et marine le
pen donc là il faut aussi être gardé un
peu de distance alors c'est vrai que les
réseaux sociaux ils démultiplient à la
fois les
comment dire le le dialogue au sommet
entre les acteurs politiques et puis le
nombre de gens qui interviennent parce
que vous avez des trouvailles aussi sur
les réseaux sociaux à des réseaux
sociaux presque spécialisée dans sa
halle gora fille ou des choses comme ça
vous vous avez une infinité de nous
quand on a travaillé on a fait avec mon
collègue jean roulmann un donc à lille
s'appelle élise et circus on raconte les
campagnes présidentielles depuis 1965 à
travers ces petites phrases ces formules
c est quelques injures mais en général
plutôt de l'humour comme le disait bruno
et on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui ce
travail là on a réfléchi à la manière de
le prolonger ce serait plus compliqué
parce qu'il faudrait il ya inclure tout
ce qui vient sur les réseaux sociaux et
sa démultiplie le chant le le le fonds à
utiliser les sources compo qu'on
pourrait utiliser parce que évidemment
non seulement ça démultiplier la force
de telle ou telle réflexion m'est venue
d'en haut mais ça démultiplie les le
nombre des locuteurs je veux dire dans
ce débat oui du coup et du coup ça c'est
vrai que ça change la nature de la
culture du clash qui a toujours existé
et qui n'était pas identifié comme tel
on ne parlait pas de clash on parlait
data company aide avec ti vont parler
d'agressivité et cette culture du clash
ou bien aussi directement des états unis
alors on le sait est une porosité entre
les deux systèmes et que la france a les
yeux rivés sur les etats-unis quoi qu'on
en dise ce qu'on l'aide qu'on déteste
les états unis ou alors que ce soit
notre modèle il ya quand même toujours
cette envie de faire six nations
répulsion wii qui a toujours une amie me
faire un peu pareil et c'est vrai que
quand on regarde les dernières campagnes
présidentielles américaines bon on en
est encore très loin mais il y a quand
même cette tentation la dalle et sur ce
champ là parce que ça ne semble le plus
contemporain possible c'est un congrès
c'est pour ça que les républicains ont
choisi le congrès sais pas ce que je
pourrais vite enfin pour éviter on est
en confiance et c'est la terminologie
utilisée aux états unis mais allez on va
on va s'appuyer sur plusieurs extraits
et un premier c'est issu du dernier prix
press club humour et politique on a je
propose trois lauréats en ribambelle
marlène schiappa jean pierre raffarin et
pour commencer sandrine rousseau la
candidate europe écologie verts qui nous
parle de son mari moi par exemple je me
vis avec un homme déconstruit j'en suis
hyper heureuse par exemple bon il ya
toujours des gens vont dire ah là là
mais voulait interdire l'infidélité vous
à les interdire les troupes vous à les
interdire les plans à trois vous allez
en garde alors je vous dirai plus
longtemps absolument je veux rassurer
tout le monde on va pas interdire les
plans à trois l'ailer d'aujourd'hui
jouent gros
si et se divise il se rétrécit quand la
droite se durcit la droite se rétrécit
alors évidemment il ya l'humour beaucoup
d'humour involontaire a très souvent
dans le dans le prix press club humour
et politique mais quand même je reprends
la phrase de jean pierre raffarin dans
la droite se durcit elle se rétrécissent
et c'est un message politique comme l
ennemi choksy c'est d'abord ça ah oui
mais si elle adore les petites formules
comme ça c'est comme la pente est raide
la route est longue et la portée
ado et c'est ce que rafa rien veut quand
il a dit de la campagne de cette
campagne ici je trouve qu'elle a été
beaucoup trop
attendait elle a été
trop trop
critique est pas mais j'ai oublié un
terreau beau ça vous reviendra pas et
pas assez proposante elle a été trop aux
critiques et pas assez proposant il ne
souvient pas de cette citation elle
m'échappe parce que c'est le cas dans
les passages que vous avez passé au
premier que la politique est plus que
jamais organique et qu'il ya un vrai
ment et cette danse freudienne toujours
le corps le corps se rappelle à nous
coincer assure évidemment vous pourrez
le jeu c'est ça aussi c'est un sport de
mes trois essais mais ce qui est
intéressant en tram il me semble que ce
qui est intéressant c'est ce qu'on voit
avec raffarin par exemple c'est
lorsqu'un bon mot une formule de ce type
veut aussi dire quelque chose et ça de
message politique parce que chez marc
les nations cherchant une rousseau c'est
de l'humour involontaire
on ne sache pas que sandrine rousseau et
un humour dévastateur mais c'est
l'humour involontaire
raffarin c'est un homme déconstruit ça
parle à une partie d'un bus sans cesse
parce que c'est vraiment un enchaînement
service a été reçue comme quelque chose
de drôle alors ça n'arrêtait pas du tout
sans son intention et ça a été reçue
pourquoi parce qu'en fait le fait de
déconstruire justement c'est une des
techniques de l'injure l'injure ça vise
à vous enlever votre humanité alors soit
on vous anime à lisant soit en vous
réduisant à un organe par exemple en
transformant un homme en femme une femme
en homme un individu en un pied ou un
ventre voyez ce genre de choses ça fait
partie des techniques de base de
l'injure et c'est pour ça que cette
expression qui se voulait un peu sa
vente a été perçu par la grande majorité
comme quelque chose d'un peu
deux étrangers un taux ridicule louise
briand fuligni le georges clemenceau qui
était quand même le guider sur la
pelouse des champions
goal pourquoi parce que lui même a été
beaucoup insulté et que lui-même savez
sont bousculés ses adversaires mais avec
un certain sens de l'image de la formule
brillant ça va être un voyou de passage
ma préférée c'est à la mort du président
félix faure du le chef de l'état vient
de mourir et il déclare en entrant dans
le néant il a dû se sentir chez lui je
trouve qu'on peut rien dire de méchant
dans un plus beau france c'est
magnifique c'est beau éthique et laisser
ces affreuses la mort du chef de l'état
12h au même moment
cela ne fait pas un homme de moins en
france où l'histoire vient de nous et
donc ses chefs d'état cela ne fait pas
donc deux mois en france c'est d'une
violence la série mis son humanité
justifié parce qu'il vous soit moi j'ai
écrit alors je voudrais pas refaire de
la publicité mais j'écris comme un homme
elle s'appelle le monde selon clemenceau
week est précisément un inventaire de
toutes les formes mais alors pourquoi il
en veut autant à celle x fort et il y
aurait autant parce que je suis il lui
reproche de ne pas avoir défendu dreyfus
et surtout ne pas avoir gracié dreyfus
ne pas avoir compris que la justice
passe et avant là la raison d'état et il
lui il y avait des griefs bien avant
s'approcher des trains sans doute andy
un petit peu un petit peu sow est un
petit peu superficiel mais
fondamentalement c'était ça donc
derrière cette méchanceté il avait aussi
la fameuse phrase sur les conditions de
la mort de deux félix faure à l'elysée
ils se croyaient césar il est mort
pomper bon ça c'est très très célèbre
mais à la limite ça c'est moi c'est
moins virulent que ce que convient aussi
grisante et bruno filmer les gens à
raison c'est vrai c'est vrai que je vous
le disais au début l' affaire dreyfus
oui plus tard certains débat de
l'entre-deux guerres sont d'une telle
violence parce que les gens sont
convaincus de part et d'autre et que
dans ce cas là les mots sont des armes
il s'agit pas de faire de l'humour non
pas seulement même si on fait de
l'humour c'est de l'humour cruel c'est
méchant parce que vraiment on s'affronte
mai mais est ce que georges clemenceau
ça n'a pas aussi desservi finalement de
se faire tant de dénis politique non
parce qu on est resté dans le registre
du bon mot contrairement à certains
polémiste de son temps aussi bien dans
son camp comme laurent tailhade hulu
dans le camp d'en face comme comme léon
daudet qui sont restés pour des formules
vraiment terrible dodo d'être était
léon blum de belette foireux chanel de
lévriers hébreu ces
deux mamelles blum enfin contrairement
donc à d'autres polémiste clemenceau
avait le sens de la formule mais avec
cette petite touche d'élégance qui fait
que ça parce que c'est quand même drôle
et qui ce qui permet effectivement de
faire un recueil
ferai pas bien d'autres il loue un peu
fait payer quand même en janvier 1920
parce que il n'a pas été élu président
de la république
du fait de la coalition de ses
adversaires tous contre clément sommet
mais c'était fin à la fois parce qu'il
avait la dent dure mais aussi pour des
raisons politiques voilà on n'avait pas
envie de la voir la présidente mais
quand même il a un petit peu payé et il
appert il a raté aussi bêtement le
perchoir terre la présidence de la
chambre des députés à une voix près
parce qu'il n'avait pas pu s'empêcher de
se moquer d'un député rural radical le
père michou qui volait des sandwichs à
la buvette un jour il l'avait poursuivie
avec un sens du temps nisand michou
michaud avait perdu sa et le jour de
l'élection du président mills ou s'en
est souvenu il a voté pour la droite et
a eu égalité des voix et méline qui
était plus âgé a obtenu le perchoir des
fois là c'est vrai la méchanceté en
politique ça space avait dit alors je
disais des choses très dernièrement sur
coup sûr sur briand et poincaré pas il
disait
poincaré c'est tout mais ne comprend
rien et brillant comprend tout mais ne
sait rien et vous avez le tableau de ces
deux personnages qui pourtant sur un
personnage très important président
république le président du conseil mais
il les avait au lac rose en une formule
alors ils étiez à la chambre des députés
on va se glisser dans les coulisses du
sénat tout de suite avec audrey états
qui qui est ici en coulisses et qui peut
nous rejoindre bonsoir audrey avec un
florilège des bons mots et des pics au
sénat des échanges que vous avez pu
récupérer alors il faut savoir que de
manière générale les échanges au sénat
même s'ils sont vifs ils restent
feutrées c'est peut-être l'une des
différences avec l'assemblée nationale
on peut ne pas être d'accord on peut le
faire savoir mais toujours dans le
respect de l'interlocuteur d'ailleurs
gérard larcher le président du sénat ils
le rappellent assez régulièrement avant
toutes les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement par exemple alors je vais
vous proposer d'écouter un premier
extrait avec la fameuse intervention du
président de la haute assemblée suivie
d'un échange entre le sénateur de la
manche philippe bas et la ministre en
charge de la citoyenneté marlène
schiappa pour vous donner un aperçu en
des échanges
chacun seront attentifs observé au cours
de nos échanges à la fois le respect des
uns et des autres le respect du temps de
parole je n'en piette nullement sur les
prérogatives de la justice je me borne à
contribuer à l'exercice d'une mission
qui est celle du parlement prévue par
l'article 15 de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme absolument monsieur le
sénateur mais on peut avoir cette joute
verbale si vous le souhaitez et empiéter
sur l'audition de la loi si tu sais vous
en êtes
friands et doué et talentueux pour cela
il ne m'appartient pas de gérer la
sécurité du président de la république
alors vous le voyez c'est très en jambes
et en s'entraînant
pêche pas les clashs de temps en temps
et c'est des moments qui ont souvent
lieu pendant les questions d'actualité
au gouvernement contre les sénateurs
pose des questions aux ministres et ces
dernières années les échanges ils ont
souvent été vifs avec le garde des
sceaux eric dupond-moretti ancien avocat
il a l'habitude des grandes plaidoiries
alors forcément ça détonne au sénat ça a
donné lieu à plusieurs passes d'armes
notamment une très importante après le
féminicide de mérignac près de bordeaux
le 4 mai dernier she has bhutta pardon
avait été tuée par son compagnon qui
avait été condamné pour violence écoutez
ces échanges très vifs tous les meurtres
de femmes ne peuvent pas être évité
celui là aurait dû l'être si vous vous
étiez donner les moyens d'appliquer des
lois que vous avez vous-même voter ma
question est donc simple n'avez vous pas
honte d'une telle inefficacité de votre
politique ce qui parfois me honte
c'est l'exploitation
c'est l'exploitation cynique
cynique et obscène d'une situation que
nous avons tous à déplorer avec beaucoup
d'émotion
géré nos métiers le monde aurait répondu
dans le respect
alors là on est évidemment sur un sujet
particulièrement grave mais senna c'est
aussi le lieu de bon bout oui je vous ai
préparé un petit concentré
d'intervention savoureuse alors pour la
première il faut des prises éléments de
contexte il faut savoir que bruno le
maire le ministre de l'économie c'est
pas le ministre le plus assidu au sénat
il a été présent trois fois aux
questions d'actualité au gouvernement en
cinq ans alors évidemment quand il est
là ça donne lieu à une ola un peu
ironique des sénateurs et puis j'ai
rajouté aussi d'autres interventions
vous allez voir
monsieur bruno le maire y avait la
parole monsieur le ministre
un seul être vous manque et tout est
dépeuplé
je pensais au fond monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs qu'il
suffisait de partir et de revenir pour
entendre la ola mais
ça n'est pas tout à fait exact tata les
cessez de vous répondre et je fais je le
fais avec avec beaucoup de beaucoup de
plaisir
mais si c'est vrai
messi
mais enfin je n'y voyais aucune offense
aux sénateurs j'aime le débat et je vous
réponds avec plaisir bon en définitive
la meilleure preuve des progrès de
l'humanité c'est quand 2500 ans nous
sommes passés de socrate show l'agora à
francis lalanne sur facebook
quel dommage que les réseaux sociaux
n'est pas exister plus tôt pour défendre
contre les dictateurs de la piqûre la
liberté de mourir en harmonie avec la
nature et ses dons parmi lesquels nous
compagnon de toujours la variole la
poliomyélite la peste et le choléra qui
ont permis aux plus grands auteurs camus
juno thomass man ou d'autres décrire les
chefs-d oeuvre immortelle de la
littérature de pandémie alors ce n'est
qu'un extrait 1 le président claude
malhuret le président du groupe les
indépendants au sénat a fait une
métaphore pendant cinq minutes et j'ai
vu que vous aviez bien aimé donc c'est à
retrouver sur publicsenat.fr pour pour
ceux qui aiment les bons mots mais oui
si vous n'avez pas entendu ce discours
franchement il est parfaitement merci
beaucoup audrey il est érudit des
savoureux il est il est drôle qu'il
était comme ça à lui serrait claude
malhuret ah oui maintenant il se régale
il régale les autres d'ailleurs c'est
vrai on a découvert que révéler au sénat
exactement vrai c'est bruno fuligni
l'hémicycle par essence est un lieu
c'est un lieu d' injure à ou pas
forcément c'est pas fait pour ça
bientôt la question l'édifice dans votre
liste l'excusé pas mal de ces deux
moments se sont déroulés
ici c'est mieux formuler c'est ce qu'on
appelle très précisément des incidents
de séance regardez moment où une séance
qui devrait être totalement respectueuse
des rives un petit peu alors des fois
c'est juste une escarmouche et à un mot
d'esprit on l'a vue permet de retrouver
un petit peu le débat normalement dans
certains cas ça se gâte ça peut aller
jusqu'à
la suspension de séance je reviens à l
affaire dreyfus on a vu une fois jaurès
qui s'est fait boxer à la tribune bon
donc ça peut dériver assez loin quelques
fois en général ces sont des
escarmouches comme cela mais ce qui est
surtout intéressant c'est que tous les
débats font l'objet d'un compte rendu et
donc c'est un jour là on ne peut pas les
renier elles sont vues elles sont
entendues elles sont notées elles sont
publiées au journal officiel même si
aujourd'hui journal officiel n'est plus
qu'en ligne on a quand même une trace
une date c'est total pour un pour
l'historien les comptes rendus de séance
sont très intéressantes ce point de vue
là parce que c'est une source
incontestable alors que beaucoup
d'injures politiques sont des injures
rapporté des petits mots méchants
quelqu'un ni dans le couloir que
quelqu'un d'autre va répéter ou va
publier danser dans ses mémoires on peut
toujours contester qu'on peut toujours
niés dans l'hémicycle non à la base un
hémicycle que ces faits pourquoi c'est
pour obliger des gens qui ne pensent pas
la même chose à partager un même lieu à
se voir et à s'écouter invention géniale
quelquefois il ya un petit peu
d'électricité dans l'air mais pourquoi
parce que c'était un lieu propice à au
théâtre c'est un théâtre il ya une scène
il y à un public il y à un acteur un
orateur donc on a toutes les composantes
d'un théâtre et donc ses lacs
effectivement peuvent se passer des
scènes surprenantes et ses skis dès
qu'on dérape finalement dès que c'est
surprenant d'excès discordants d'excès
disruptif peut-être d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui pour finir par passer de
mode ce moment là encore un peu à la
mode
l'office est intéressant c'est où est la
limite alors injures et humour mais
c'est que ça en fait de nos sujets
d'aujourd'hui si notre sujet notre
succès rejoint en tous cas ça se rejoint
mais oui mais est-ce qu'on peut se
passer de la juge sur quand même en a
l'air de dire que là c'est faut toujours
que ce soit un petit peu vachard pour
que ça ait un certain retard mais la
polémique ça fait partie de la politique
il ya plus il ya tout un clavier dans la
polémique il ya l'insinuation skiff
quelque chose de douloureux dans
l'humour oui l'humour
effectivement en cup c'est pour ça que
les anglais qui résiste très bien aux
difficultés ont dû bout parce qu'ils
sont capables et ils apprécient au
contraire d'avoir deux sont à résister à
d'ailleurs au parlement britannique
l'humour est très codifié l'humour est
très utilisé dans les cautionner un
curieux mélange c'est à dire est ce que
le plus talentueux et celui qui arrive à
blessé longue ou celui qui arrive à
faire rire l'assemblée avec de
l'ambition vous mettez les rires de
vrais côté vous vous renforcez et les
injures dont on se relève pas regarder
ce pauvre garde des sceaux arpaillange
lalas de santini trente ans après la
france entière la connais par coeur
saint louis rendait la justice sous un
chêne arpaillange la rend comme un gland
formule et c'est en cela que certaines
attaques son retour il ya quelques
exemples sur les attaques physiques
jean garrigues vous en avait une qui
frappent françois bayrou aussi je suis
le d'andré santini ah oui on se bat et
roux la seule chose qui décolle ce sont
les oreilles
l'à-propos à 5 ans et tournage et 2002
où il avait très mauvais sondages est au
départ mais ça c'est typiquement de
l'humour français
oh on toucherait esic c'est très souvent
une des armes de ceux de ce alors de
dalton dalphond ce type de dalle food
halal food hier par dont les communards
lisait c'est un crapaud là on était dans
quelque chose de vraiment très très très
dur là c'est plutôt sympathique et en
même temps ça c'est très fort ses
tresses et percutant c'est quelque chose
qui est qui qui veut dire quelque chose
de très grave pour pour françois bayrou
mais s'est dit avec voile à fleurets
mouchetés ces sachets bayrou en termes
de sondages il n'y a que les oreilles
qui décolle pas surprendre et santini
des totalement assumée d'ailleurs cette
déclaration mais là j'ai trouvé dans
votre livre de cuisine souvent gagné le
prix du c'est vrai françois bayrou
n'était pas au rsa initie bleu jean
louis borloo est cité par le canard
enchaîné en juillet 2011 borloo ça
s'écrit bo rl est double
0,06 et sfr alors je vous ai proposé de
choisir une une séquence une séquence
vidéo relativement
récente
pichot si vous avez opté pour le débat
entre bruno le maire et eric zemmour
c'était le 9 décembre dernier sur france
2 regarde un extrait oui ils doivent
choisir entre les lois islamiques le
code la charia
et là je crois que c'est tout s'est pas
trouvé bien sûr fait peut-être fait
l'âne pour avoir du son comme disait mon
père et ça vous va très bien
deuxièmement sur le bataclan savez
monsieur je n'ai jamais dit
pardonnez-moi de sa liberté selon le
président de la république
on respecte les hommes et des femmes qui
vous parle
fait l'âne pour avoir le son pourquoi
vous avez choisi cette séquence à l'inpi
chaud ce n'est pas ce que eric zemmour
m'a beaucoup m'a profondément agacé
profondément agacé parce que je trouve
que s'il y en a 1 franchement il n'a pas
beaucoup d'esprit il ne cherche pas à
plaisanter ne cherchez pas d'étendre ses
auditeurs ça c'est le pam a pris 0 ça je
suis entièrement d'accord eric zemmour
il cherche un peu trop cherche un peu
trop à se faire remarquer japon bon moi
je suis pas du tout d'accord avec ça
mais je trouve qu'il a cherché à blesser
pour une ou le maire quand il l'a traité
dany l'a dit mais qui méritait le bonnet
d'âne j'estime que pour quelqu'un qui
est au gouvernement depuis cinq ans qui
reçoit tous les matins dans son bureau à
bercy les représentants des professions
des cultivateurs des grévistes de jeunes
16 ou des
ddd femme en colère y compris des femmes
aux colères des budgets qui sont jamais
assez grande il est vraiment extrêmement
des douze des quand même il est vraiment
dévoué il est entièrement à sa tâche il
maintient l'économie de france on ne
sait pas parce qu'il est très optimiste
en même temps il n'est pas drôle mais il
est très optimiste mais j'ai décrit bien
en revanche à il écrit bien évident et
vite quel talent on a là où j'écris ça
c'est sûr et on a l'impression qu'on
entrevoit même des scènes comment dire
que que la morale pour éprouver dans ses
livres dans les livres de la planète il
est incroyable et une scène érotique
célèbre dans un de france quand sa mère
dans sa baignoire lorsqu'il pendant une
séance de questions une prestation va
raconter à cette heure mais bon séance
de questions à l'assemblée jamais qui
nous regardent donc nous allons éviter
pour les oreilles mais les critiques
contre contre eric zemmour puiser dans
le petit dictionnaire des injures
politique celle ci signée jean baptiste
djebbari c'est un faux dur et sous les
faux durs se cache les vrais soumis
une autre signée de jean luc mélenchon
le zemmouri ce temps ça existe c'est un
pays où les femmes sont rabaissées où il
ya la peine de mort ou les homosexuels
célibat sa wii wheel tac ça s'appelle
l'arabie saoudite allez-y vous serez
heureux là bas c'est vrai que par ces
attaques eric zemmour ça c'était parti
des citations vous avez évidemment
rajouter dans le temps dans cette
nouvelle édition
il attaque il reçoit c'est d'une logique
absolue implacable oui comment dirais-je
eric zemmour est dans une logique
polémique je pense que c'est aussi un
lecteur des polémistes du 19e siècle
il a un avis s'inspire de gens aussi
bien de victor hugo que de henri
rochefort c'est cette culture là alors
qui est un petit peu éloigné de ce que
l'on décrivait tout à l'heure c'est à
dire des petites piques humoristique et
donc dans certains cas ça
ça passe pas ça ne passe pas uniquement
oui le fait d' animalisés l'adversaire
c'est une technique de base de l'injure
et en particulier c'est ce qu'ils
utilisent aussi les caricaturistes mais
même aujourd'hui les cats éric à turris
font attention
font attention et là tout à coup on a
une sortie un petit peu un petit peu
plus vive lui-même lors ce qui était
intéressant c'est lorsqu'il ya eu ce
débat entre zemmouri mélenchon parce
qu'en fait on avait l'impression qu'ils
avaient plaisir à se balancer des
méchancetés l'un l'autre avec avec
l'idée qu'on est des polémistes on a le
cuir épais c'est pas grave voilà je
reçois
voilà exactement
mais c'est une conception du débat
public qui est plus pour moi 19e siècle
que contemporaine c'est l'héritage
d'henri rochefort de sa part on appelait
le prince des polémistes britannique
effet biographie de lui et qui accueille
qui a été pendant 50 ans en passe en
dehors de l'extrême gauche à l'extrême
droite mais qui avait il faut lire les
éditoriaux de dents et rochefort dans
l'intransigeant à chaque fois c'est à la
fois un plaisir de lecture et puis on a
un peu un moule corps parce qu un haut
le coeur bardon parce que c'est quand
même très très souvent très très dur le
méchant alors on va parler un peu des
débats présidentiels et pour commencer
laetitia on va se pencher sur un exemple
américain vous vous dites que
l'insultent peut payer vous prenez
l'exemple d'un de l'un des débats entre
joe biden et bien et donald trump où on
a vu finalement que six pidjot c'était
drôle endormi c'était comme ça que
donald trump l'a appelé pendant toute la
campagne il avait même dit aussi de lui
que par dont c'était le lèche cul
d'obama voilà donc il y aller fort
évidemment eric zemmour a aussi donald
trump en tête un donald trump ses
champions toutes catégories de la jure
outrancière et donc est soudainement 6 1
joe biden s'est réveillé voilà et il a
attaqué lui aussi regarder
et de poing et de
la drogue
et encore nous avons été soft parce
qu'il l'a traité de clown de caniche de
poutine et du pire président des états
unis donc il y est allé fort joe biden
mais avec son style c'est à dire qu'il
n'a pas fait du trump trump il appelé
hillary clinton la crapule il a même dit
dans le dernier débat avec hillary
clinton sage nasty woman ça veut dire
quelle salle femme et tout le monde
avait pensé qu'on allait lui coûter sa
place finalement il a gagné mais buydens
s'est dit ok je vais pas me laisser
faire je vais attaquer moi aussi rentrer
dans cette culture du clash mais avec
mon style c'est à dire tout en restant
respectueux et sa vie de casser l'image
dont vous parliez ça a cassé son image
il il a gagné des voix il a gagné le
président gary ses traits ce qui était
très frappant c'est que vous ayez trump
qui qui interpelle directement élite
vous vous avez fait vous avez fait et
bayonne qui prend une distance qui est
la distance aux fondus des du 10 ans us
réguler justement dans les assemblées
dans les débats aux politiques et qui
dit il ce ce personnage soit là et en
même temps une manière de se distancer
de lui où le réseau est de le mettre un
peu à distance d'effectivement du monde
politique respectable enseignement bruno
fuligni le débat présidentiel
aujourd'hui en france c'est pas le bon
moment pour pour injurier en général on
on conseille aux candidats d'être de ne
pas être le plus agressif parce que le
plus agressif serait le perdant en fait
le vrai gagnant c'est celui qui est
agressée et qui ripostent
lorsque vous répliqué l'homme du passé
l'homme du passif là vous marquez un
plat c'est françois mitterrand qui
implique
tout à fait bon le mois président de la
république et tout l'anaphore à ce
moment là le débat basculé alors c'est
totalement irrationnel ça veut rien dire
sur le fond etc mais on si on considère
ce débat du second tour comme une joute
il ya un moment où on marque des points
et généralement c'est quand l'un des
candidats attaqué a le génie de
répliquer de leurs généralement ce sont
des répliques qui ont été préparés par
ont été mûri un travail énorme coeur de
ces expressions là elles font
véritablement partie de notre patrie et
passionnante ya une citation de françois
mitterrand à propos de valéry giscard
d'estaing on est au quasiment un an
avant dès le 24 juin 1981 trouver dans
votre dictionnaire je le verrais bien à
ces barons du chômage marquis des
inégalités compte de la hausse des prix
duc de la technocratie prince de
l'électoralisme et au roi de
l'anesthésié là aussi a quand même il ya
quand même un talon un talent de
d'écriture il y avait un talent il ya
beaucoup de moqueries et puis quand on
est le candidat de la gauche c'est
intéressant aussi de souligner le
caractère aristocratique 1 c'est
l'époque où ou giscard est caricaturé en
week-ends bon il donc c'est intéressant
politiquement aussi pour françois
mitterrand était peut-être un petit peu
aristocratique lui aussi dans ses
attitudes dans sa façon de parler
c'était une façon de se raccrocher au
peuple en disant voilà lui par contre il
se prend pour un baron et c'est un faux
nobles et son souligné la faiblesse son
adversaire qui est qui avait pris une
image de s'ouvre un peu recroquevillés
dans ce réseau très différent de ce
qu'il était en 74 quand il arrivait
qu'ils regardaient la france sur tout le
monde parlait du château en parlant de
duels ça me faisait penser à une une
joute fameuse mettrai mes mais très
belle 2 je connais certainement bruno à
la chambre des députés ont passé six
années entre jaurès et mon clemenceau et
à la fin d'une joute quelqu'un qui a été
très très longue et sa durée d'ailleurs
plusieurs séances je
l'aurais sdi à
clemenceau non plutôt clemenceau dia à
jaurès vous n'êtes pas dieu l'autre lui
répond qu on est pas le diable et
clemenceau a le dernier mot qu'en savez
vous alors c'est mal c'est très très
beau parce que c'est parce que derrière
ça il y à l'idéalisme de 1,2 jaurès le
pragmatisme de clemenceau la méchanceté
de clemenceau aussi et puis ça se
termine par cette cette boutade un
dernier mot finalement l'injure est ce
que c'est pas quand même un signe de
bonne santé de démocratie quand on reste
dans l'injure c'est à dire quand on ne
verse ni dans la diffamation ce qui est
autre chose à un nid dans l'appel au
meurtre quand on est dans l'injure je
dirais qu'il ya de l'injure de bon aloi
ya de l'injure qui fait partie de la
polémique qu'on le veuille ou non depuis
1789 et d'ailleurs
parce que nous somme toute une équipe
dont jean avoir rassemblé les citations
qui sont dans ce petit dictionnaire des
injures politique eh bien on en trouve
que dans les périodes où l'appel où la
presse est libre quand la presse des
plus libres il ya plus d'un joueur merci
beaucoup le petit dictionnaire des
injures politique c'est aux éditions du
rocher elysées circus histoires drôles
et cruels des présidentielles c'est chez
tallandier et puis laetitia je rappelle
que vous publiez la tentation du clown
aux éditions s'est jeté un chat stealth
et ça c'est bientôt noël allait acheter
des bons livres et puis tiens jean louis
debré de salah aussi c'est un livre il
aurait pu être invité de l'émission le
titre de son livre c'est quand les
politiques nous faisait rire il est
l'invité demain matin dorian monsigny
dans bonjour chez vous merci toutes les
équipes de public sénat à la rédaction
de sens public je vais les cités parce
que c'est la dernière avant les fêtes
isabelle pincer
élections chef autres chauvel du sisp à
nevers à la programmation benjamin
rolland ddcs et notre jeune journaliste
plein de talent perrine tarneaud la
directrice de l'information merci à
toutes et à tous de m'accompagner